it's great to be joined today by dr.
alot yom tov who is a principal
researcher at microsoft research he
studies what internet data can tell us
about health and medicine he is also the
author of crowd-sourced health how what
you do on the internet will improve
medicine uh dr. yom tov it's so great to
have you on you know we talked about
this a little bit a year or two ago in
the context of predicting or tracking
blue breakouts in the United States but
let's approach this more generally first
give us a sense of some of the different
areas in which internet search data can
be used to learn about health and
medicine so perhaps we should start by
saying what what do we mean by internet
data and roughly speaking it's what we
generate the data that we generate when
we browse the internet and this can be
things like the search queries that we
ask Google or Bing or Yahoo it can be
the things that we write on social media
on Twitter or Facebook and sometimes
it's the things that patients will write
on patient forums and things of that
nature and over the past several years
we've realized that these data are
actually a boon for medical research and
they can help in roughly speaking three
main areas the first as you mentioned is
things like the flu where many people
will use the internet to ask about the
flu but many fewer people will actually
bother visiting the doctor so we
essentially see or have data for many
more people who have the flu then
traditional medical researchers another
area is when we were on to have people
reporting things to edge with which they
find difficult to report this can be
because they're embarrassed by it or
because they just don't realize that
these are things that are related to one
another and I can give an example later
and the last is when the internet is the
primary source or the primary point at
which people interact when they want to
find some information about some medical
condition or when they go online in
order to chat to other people about
their medical
so my my first question is more of a of
a logistical question which is as a
researcher looking into this data how do
you account for example for uh adjusting
data for uh more or less internet access
for example so if you were to look at
data about could be flu but there's
probably better examples that might be
more regionally regionally oriented or
impacted how do you account when you
analyze the data for the reality that a
population that may have a higher
incidence of a particular condition or
symptom may have a higher or lower rate
of access to the Internet in the first
place just as an example of how you
would you would manipulate or evaluate
data so in some cases we know how many
people have access to the Internet and
how many of them actually use the
internet to search for that medical
condition but in other cases I mean if
you take the extreme if people don't go
online we will never see them but that
is becoming a smaller and smaller
minority both in terms of income and in
terms of age where we had problems in
the past but they're slowly disappearing
we do know how different demographics of
people access the internet and so we can
compensate for these kinds of effects
it's not always critical to do that if
you're looking at a specific population
and you just want to be able to say
something about that population in
others it's very important to be able to
say this represents a very specific
portion of the population and we know
how to adjust for that when it comes to
the flu vaccine and I this is sort of on
my mind I recently got my flu shot
earlier this week and it's one that is
often mentioned when we talked about
using search trends to to make some
assessments uh how can we distinguish or
in what ways have you research different
aspects of flu vaccination and by that I
mean on the one hand there's the
question of interest in the flu vaccine
or a portion of people that are actually
getting the vaccine and separately from
that there's the estimating of the
effectiveness of a flu
vaccine what are you looking at when you
try to estimate the effectiveness of a
flu vaccine is it searches about up or
is it particular searches or what else
is it so it's really a combination of
all of the above the first kinds of
research that used internet data to look
at the flu try to estimate how many
people actually have the flu in a given
area at a given time and Google had a
website called Google Flu Trends which
try to report this in the way that this
was done was just say let's count the
number of people asking about specific
issues related to the flu in each of
these geographic areas we have looked at
a slightly different question which
relates to the flu vaccine and that was
specifically in England where they ran a
very interesting vaccination campaign to
vaccinate children primary school
children against the flu where the
question was is this an effective way to
prevent the flu not in these children so
much but in say older populations and
younger populations which are more at
risk if they actually suffer from the
flu and they ran a very interesting
experiment where they vaccinated these
children in seven cities in England and
did not vaccinate in all the rest of
England and then they came to our
collaborators in to us and asked was
this vaccine effective and what we did
was to compare the number of people who
were asking about the flu in these Seven
Cities compared to people in other
cities of course we had to compensate
for demographics and for other factors
but the end result was that we were able
to show that indeed this vaccine was
highly effective in preventing the fluid
reduced the the number of cases by
between 25 and 30 percent give us some
some examples of sort of the exciting
advancements that may come from this
type of research and I think one side of
it is what can we sort of assess but
looking in the rearview mirror about of
incidents of something or or what we've
been talking about so
but in a more forward-looking way what
what sort of doors are open by being
able to do this type of research I think
there are two areas one is the more
personal one which is for example a few
years ago we were able to show that we
can help people with say mood disorders
know that they're going to have an
episode a manic episode up to a day
before they actually have it and that
helps them prepare for it or a few
months ago colleagues of mine showed
that by looking at the series of
searches that people make they were able
to predict that a person has specific
forms of cancer before that person knew
it now granted this is not accurate
enough at this point to be to provide a
screening tool but it shows the the way
that this may be going in the sense that
some years in the future we may be able
to tell people look the the searches
that you've asked being or Google
they're not individual symptoms that
you're experiencing they may be
connected to each other and you may want
to talk to your physician about why
you're experiencing these symptoms so
let me pause there just make sure that's
fascinating I wanted let me follow up on
that a little bit and then we'll move on
to the second part so conceivably if
there was enough data to say that you
know when people search for XY and Z in
this particular way within some span of
time of each other even if they are not
aware necessarily even that these
symptoms or searches are related we
might be able to have enough data where
those searches together could be seen as
establishing that someone is at
particularly high risk for a condition
that may not even be obvious to them
based on those searches and your browser
or whatever tool you're using might be
able to say hey you search for this two
weeks ago and this will week ago in this
today you should talk to a doctor about
whatever it is that that they might be
at risk for is that the idea yeah so so
with some forms of cancer let's say
ovarian cancer the symptoms are benign
and each of the symptoms by itself does
not cause people to worry or does not
them too worried enough to go and see a
physician and so you need something like
a program or a search engine that runs
in the background and says and collects
these symptoms to say you know the the
bloating of today and the say the the
fullness that you asked about yesterday
they're not independent of each other
and there is somehow related and you
should see a doctor and the problem with
something like ovarian cancer is that a
lot of times by the time women get to
their physician it's very late into the
disease where because of this problem
that each of the symptoms was not
worrying enough if we can somehow look
at all these symptoms together and say
you know there's a pattern here and you
should be you take this into account
then we may be able to help these people
to nudge them in the right direction
fascinating and then the second element
of this that you were getting to the
second element it relates to population
health and there are questions that
epidemiologists and and medical
practitioners want to ask about entire
populations and it's very expensive or
even sometimes impossible to answer them
let me give you an example a few years
ago there was a law passed in Israel
that forbade showing models fashion
models with a brain mass with a body
mass index that was very low and the
basic idea was that these very thin
models somehow influence people to
develop an eating disorder now that's a
question that's really hard to measure
in the physical world how do you know
that the billboard you see when you
drive to work or those ads in the
newspaper where you see a very thin
model cause somebody to develop an
eating disorder if you wanted to measure
this in the real world you'd have to go
and collect a very large sample of say
you know thousands or tens of thousands
of people and see what they see and then
analyze those data for us it was a much
simpler exercise because we
see what people look for online and we
can ask are they browsing these very
thin celebrities do they see their
images and then later on do they develop
an eating disorder or is there in some
indicator that they have an eating
disorder and so answering these very
difficult questions about populations is
much easier in certain cases with
internet data well the work is
absolutely fascinating we've been
speaking with dr. alladi amitabh who is
a principal researcher at Microsoft
Research he also is the author of
crowd-sourced health how what you do on
the internet will improve medicine uh
thank you so much for talking to us
about this today thank you very much
David